from attacks that killed dozens of
nigerian soldiers just days before the
summit to rising violence that has
killed hundreds in mali and burkina faso
in june security is at the top of the
summit's agenda the meeting has taken on
a sense of urgency as the number of
violent attacks by armed groups across
the region continues to rise
in 2019 there were no attacks in
africa's benin and in togo but in 2021
we witnessed 13 attacks in ivory coasts
five attacks in benin and one attack in
togo and it is expected that by the end
of the year would have almost more than
double
the region's politics are also being
debated with developments in mali guinea
and burkina faso under review after
military course overthrew the civilian
governments in all three countries
we thought we had deepened our
democracies to be resilient in how we
respond to the type of crisis afflicting
us
but we now know
that the democracies were building was
on the surface
so we now need to look at how we are
deepening and building democracy
beyond just
electing leaders
on a frequent basis
he says the region's leaders must police
themselves and respect constitutional
term limits in addition to providing
leadership for their people
another concern for west african leaders
is rise of protest against inflation and
shortages analysts expect more
demonstrations like the one recently
seen in ghana sparked by rising cost of
living and they say there is little
regional leaders can do to stop this
from happening
the meeting will usher in new leadership
for the echoes commission with a leaner
bureaucracy a move that's received
praise from civil society across the
region
observers are now keenly watching where
the financial commitments met at the
summit by the member states will result
in an actual increase in funding ahmed
idris al jazeera accra ghana